heute nachmittag am nachmittag haben wir
dieses schreiben aus dem juni 2020
erhalten und das schreiben hat es
wirklich in sich das ist der brief von
vier europäischen gesundheitsminister
unter anderen der deutsche
gesundheitsminister jens sparen indem
sie sozusagen die verantwortung für die
beschaffung von impfstoff an die eu an
die eu kommissionspräsident ursula von
der leyen übertragen haben und wie wir
erfahren haben aus unseren quellen haben
sieht das nicht ganz freiwillig getan es
war der ausdrückliche wunsch der
bundeskanzlerin
und es war auch der ausdrückliche wunsch
von eu-kommissionspräsident in oslo von
der leyen dass die verantwortung für die
beschaffung des impfstoffs die jetzt so
schrecklich schief gegangen ist bei der
eu-kommission gebündelt wird
und deswegen wollen wir entspannen und
seine drei minister kollegen die sich
bis dahin darum gekümmert hatten genug
impfstoff für europa zu beschaffen und
auch auf einem guten weg war genug
impfstoff zu beschaffen wurden diese
vier gezogen genötigt veranlasst wie
auch immer man das formulieren möchte
diesen brief zu schreiben und in
unterwürfig ssten geradezu demütigen ton
ursula von der leyen zu versichern dass
es ihr leider sozusagen bisher sagte
parallel strukturen gekommen sei bei der
beschaffung des impfstoffs dass das aber
nicht mehr vorkomme und man ab sofort
ausschließlich der eu-kommission die
beschaffung des impfstoffs überlassen
würde und das hat dazu geführt die wie
nele lieber max wie wir inzwischen
wissen wie sie sehen sehen sie nichts
viel zu wenig impfstoff für alle
menschen in europa julian einmal
abschließend du hast du sagt viel zu
wenig impfstoff für uns alle wer trägt
dafür die verantwortung der
gesundheitsminister die kanzlerin oder
die eu-kommission die operative
verantwortung für das was in den letzten
monaten in deutschland passiert das
liegt mit sicherheit bei
gesundheitsministerien sparen aber die
frage die sich in den nächsten monaten
stellen wird ist wer trägt die
politische verantwortung dafür dass es
in deutschland und in ganz europa zu
spät und zu wenig impfstoff gibt und
nach diesem brief und dem was wir um
diesen brief wissen ist das verfahren
ganz eindeutig so gewesen dass der
gesundheitsminister in deutschland
sparen
geradezu gedrängt wurde dazu von der
bundeskanzlerin die verantwortung für
die beschaffung des impfstoffs abzugeben
eben nach hause an ursula von der leyen
zur erinnerung das verfahren was hier
entspannen
minister vorher gewählt haben zu viert
für ganz europa zu beschaffen das hat so
wie man es heute sagen kann halbwegs
funktioniert das was dann später raus
wurde auf wunsch der bundeskanzlerin
das hat so gar nicht mehr funktioniert
deswegen kann man durchaus sagen dass
die politische verantwortung für das
debakel was wir da gerade erleben
durchaus direkt bei der bundeskanzlerin
liegt und bei ursula von der leyen in
der verantwortung der eu kommission denn
dort sollte beschafft werden
für alle bürger ausreichend rechtzeitig
in der eu und angekommen ist davon wir
haben es gesehen als die laster aufgeben
und kaum was drin war viel zu wenig
energien für diese exklusiven einblicken
dankeschön an